SECOND 3-POINT HIT FOR OKLAHOMA
CITY, THE FIRST NOM HORFORD.
10-3 SUNS LEAD.
>> Ann: YOU HAVE THAT MUCH TIME
TO SET UP AND TAKE THE SHOT, YON
BEING AGGRESSIVE IS GETTING TO
THE FREE-THROW LINE WHICH THE
SUNS HAVE REALLY STRUGGLED IN
FT
HALF.
DONOVAN WITH A RUNNER OFF THE
GLASS.
MITCHELL'S FIRST BUCKET IN
QUARTER NUMBER TWO.
I HAVE BEEN ASKED THIS BY NBA AF
MENTORING FOR DEVIN BOOKER?
AFTER SIX YEARS, I AM NOT SURE
YOU CAN REALLY DO THIS BUT YOU
CAN PROBABLY TEACH AND GUIDE.
HE'S ALSO HERE TO MAKE SURE THIS
TIPPED AND -- SUNS HAVE IT.
SHOT CLOCK IS SIX SECONDS AHEAD
OF THE GAME CLOCK.
CHRIS PAUL AT THE END OF THE
SCREEN-AND-ROLL.
THAT'S WHY THEY GOT CHRIS PAUL.
>> Scott: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
SAW -- WHAT HAPPENS HIS
TEAMMATES SO EXCITED THEY JUMPED
AND GAVE HIM A FLAT TIRE.
THIS IS WHY YOU GET CHRIS PAUL.
HE CAN ALWAYS GET A SHOT AND HE
IS NOT AGAIN.
INSTEAD, HITS BRIDGES.
THE WING THREE, NOT THERE.
AYTON KEEPS IT ALIVE, THOUGH.
STARTERS BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR
THE SUNS.
GOOD HANDS BY LONZO BALL.
>> Dave: THE FIRST LEAD TONIGHT
FOR PHOENIX.
GOOD HANDS BY JOHNSON.
OUT OF BOUNDS, PELICANS WILL
KEEP IT WITH TEN TO SHOOT.
>> Mark: HERE'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
CHRIS PAUL
>> Chris: THESE TWO TEAMS WILL
SEE EACH OTHER NEXT SATURDAY AT
PHOENIX SUNS ARENA, LIKE
BANKERS LIFE FIELDHOUSE, ITS
UNDERGOING RENOVATION.
THERE IS IS A TWO-YEAR PROCESS.
SPEECH ARE SIMPLY AMAZING.
HE'S BEEN DOING THIS FOR ABOUT
HIS 16TH YEA
>> Ann: LOVE IT, 15-FOOTER
FREE-THROW.
UNDER 5 TO GO.
THEIS WITH 3, PAUL WITH THE
REBOUND. THAT LEFT
HAND.
>> Ann: HE'S HAD 14 ASSISTS AND
14 POINTS, HE'S LOOKING TO PASS,
LANE.E CROSSOVER, COMING
SHOT CLOCK DOWN TO 10.
>> PAUL, THE LAST TW JUBILATIONE
DEVASTATION HE HAS CAUSED THE
KNICKS OFF THE BOUNCE.
MIKE: THE KNICKS FINDING OUT WHY
THE PHOENI